on travaillait trop on se levait trop de
bonheur c'est qu'on
s'endormait on s'endormait souvent et on
était battu parce que les bêtes s'en
allaient ell faisaient du mal et ça
n'était pas de la faute de de
l'enfant je sais que je suis née le 25
avril à 7h du matin c'est
tout c'était mon père qui nous a
attrapé il avais pas de docteur on
nallait pas chercher un docteur pour
attraper un enfant quand il naissait on
nallait pas les chercher les docteurs
quand on les faisait mais on nallait pas
les chercher quand il venait au
monde nous y étions quatre frères et
quatre
demi-frères le premier lit il y avait
trois filles un garçon et le deuxième
lit il y a trois garçons et une
fille ça y est il y a pas moyen de
voir c'est difficile
c
c c
c nous que
nousit qu toute une journée derrière un
buisson là dans de la neige vous savez
on n'avit pas choix avec des petits
sabots de bois on emportait un petit
chauffe-pied qu'on appelait on se
chauffait puis on allumait du feu mais
c'est souvent que le feu ne brûlait pas
le bois était trop mouillé vous savez on
était pas heureux s'il fallait le refire
j'aurais du mal à M faire moi tu m'as
prends une chanson et non je n'en sais
pas mon petit moi du chanson je ne
chantais pas moi moi quand j'étais
petite quand ma sœur est parti mes sœurs
et nées sont partis à 21 ans
puisqueelles étaient nées en 1901 et moi
j'étais en 1910 alors ça fait que quand
elles sont parties moi j'étais bien
jeune alors j'étais obligé de garder les
troupeaux de
mouton vous savez quand vous aviez 10
ans quand on faisait lever le matin à 6h
c'était le jour là qui marchait quand le
jour pointait tout le monde se levait et
ben on faisait garder les bêtes bon
après vous arriviez vous mangiez un peu
de soupe du pain et il fallait aller
toute la journée dans le champ en plein
soleil conduire les bêtes auou ben
moissonner et ben le soir vous étiez
tellement fatigué qu'on s'endormait dans
les prés mais voyez-vous on travaillait
trop on se levait trop de bonheur c'est
qu'on
s'endormait on s'endormait souvent et on
était battu parce que les bêtes s'en
allaient faisait du mal et ça n'était
pas de la faute de de l'enfant vous
savez vous aviez pas peur toute seule
non je n'avais jamais eu peur parce que
voyez on ne voyait rien c'était pas
comme aujourd'hui
hein non je n'ai jamais eu peur vous
n'avez jamais connu votre maman ah non
pas 18 mois moi je suis née en 10 le 25
avril elle est morte en 12 le 20 janvier
alors je ne pouvais pas connaître ma
mère je n'ai aucune souvenance de ma
mère et je ne l'ai jamais vu en photo ni
rien je suis encore à la veille de dire
maman ça doit être un énorme trou ça ben
oui mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez quand
on est élevé là on prend son sort comme
il
vient on me dit que je ris toujours
alors si je je ris toujours parce que je
suis
bête
et votre papa il était comment il était
et ben c'était un un brave homme il nous
aimit bien mais vous comprenez il ne
pouvait pas faire face à tout est-ce que
vos parents étaient
pauvres j'étais pauvre oui et non mais
comme mon père était un travailleur et
quand même il nous donnait à manger
voyez-vous on on na jamais crevé de faim
comme on dit des fois qu'on aurait mangé
bien ailleurs mais pour dire qu'on a
crevé de faim on n pas crevé de faim on
ne mangeait pas de viande tous les jours
on vivait avec son produit qu'on
faisait mais mon père savait très bien
faire ses affaires il comptait très bien
et il connaissait ses chiffres quand il
avait vendu une bête il disait ben tu
vas le marquer met un un met un 2 ou un
ou un 10 il savait ce qu'il voulait
faire il était un peu Avard ah si oui
quand il avait mis ses sous dans son
trou de mur pour les sortir c'était
difficile il était avare oui mais enfin
il était honnête il faut le reconnaître
il n'a jamais fait perdre personne et
puis il nous a élevé quand même vous
savez il nous disait quand on allait au
foire comme ça se promener et ben il
nous disait vous toucherez avec vos yeux
et vous regarderez avec
vous-même il était sévère votre père oui
mais enfin pas trop brute quand même
mais il était Savit dans le temps il
étaient tellement soup les gens ce
n'était pas comme aujourhui Thas il
était
sévère mais il nous avait toujours
défendu d'aller voler les
gens comme ça vous savez on allait dans
dans les vignes on prenait des raisins
on nous disait tu y iras pas manger les
raisins mais on y allait quand
même enfin s'il le savait il nous
fâchait vous m'avez pas parlé de votre
grand-mère ma grand-mère quand elle me
regarder vous savez elle était pas jeune
elle avait la catarace elle ne voyait
même pas bien clair les soirs je
couchais avec elle elle me mettait mes
petits pieds dans sa chemise une grande
chemise en toile qu'elle et puis elle me
disait comme ça approche-toi de moi et
puis moi je ne voulais pas alors elle me
elle pri alors je lui disais pourquoi
grand-mère que tu fais ça ah ben elle me
disait c'est pour ta pauvre mère qui est
morte alors je lui demandais toujours
pourquoi qu'elle faisait ça alors je la
voyais toujours prier et puis quand je
boudais qu'elle me fa elle me
disait nous et
alors c'était pour me consoler qu'elle
disait ça alors quand elle me disait
comme ça alors je ne Bouis plus parce
que je voulais pas qu'il me dise
toujours
ça c'était une
chanson céit une une histoire de
d'enfant voyez-vous et je me rappelle
bien que j'avais un petit tablierier
puis des petits sabots tout cassés puis
ma grand-mère lendemain matin elle a dit
au fur de m'apporter des petitsill des
petits Sabau jaunes et ben j'étais
contente et puis elles m'ont percé les
oreilles avec une grosse aiguille à à
repriser et puis elle m'avait acheté des
petites boucles d'oreilles et j'étais
contente c'était la première fois que je
navais mon père m'a retiré l'école
j'avais 9 ans et ben je travaillais bien
en ce
moment et et je travaillais bien plus
jeune que je enfin que je conduisais les
vaches au près pu quand mon père la
bourré il fallait un devant pour la
guider pour guider les vaches et ben on
était tout gosse qu'on faisait ça on
allait qu'à l'école le jour où il y
avait de la neige du mauvais temps
l'école sans doute n'était pas
obligatoire et c'était loin l'école oh
je faisais bien 3 kg kè tous les jours
quand j'allais à
l'école moi j'étais à l'école 2 hiver et
j'y allais quand ça faisait mauvais
temps P à 9ant on nétait pas on éétait
pas
bien développé vous savez dans ce tempsl
on voyait rien monsieur André à ants on
était pas plus développé qu'un enfant de
5 ans tout à l'heure on travaillait mais
on ne voyait rien on voit
onait même pas d'HE dans la mais alors
on vivait comme ça ça n'empêchait pas
qu'on était aussi honnête que maintenant
mais on vivait
misérablement et vous ne saviez pas lire
non presque
pas je sais me signer je fais des
lettres mais voyez-vous je ne fais je
n'ai aucune autographe voyez-vous je
vous
écrirai comprendrez ce que je veux vous
dire mais il y a pas
d'autographe vous auriez bien aimé
apprendre à lire non allez venez allez
parce que voyez-vous quand j'ai quitté
l'école j'avais 9 ans quand il pleuvait
les jours comme qu'on ne fais qu'on ne
pouvait pas aller dehors je prenais un
livre je
lisais alors comme il y avait des petits
frères il fallait les tricoter n'est-ce
pas alors on me disait de poser mon lit
et de travailler n'est pas il y avait
toujours du travail à faire casser du
bois faire ceci faire cela alors
voyez-vous j'avais pris ça à cœur vous
voyez je prenais ça à cœur ça fait
qu'après je suis complètement dégoûté de
lire et j'ai trouvé des gens qui ont
voulu me faire lire parce que j'étais
chez des
instituteurs mais non je n'avais pas
pris ça me disait rien et dans ce moment
ça n'était pas comm aujourd'hui vous
savez on me disait oh même même que tu
ne seras pas lire tu mangeras du pain
quand même en effet j'ai toujours manger
du pain quand même mais enfin
aujourd'hui je le
regrette enfin je sais lire quand même
je
lis comme aujourd'hui je suis zéro il y
a 50 ans quand mon mari était à la
guerre je faisais ses lettre Y allit
très bien n'est-ce pas je me faisais
comprendre quand vous vous souvenez de
cette période de la petite enfance c'est
des bons
souvenirs pas pas énormément pas
énormément on s'en rappelle bien sûr
quand on était petit que les parents
vous donnaient une blouse alors on vous
l' metter 8 jours à l'endroit et 8 jours
à l'envers pour économiser le
savon moi je l'ai pas fait à à mes
enfants mais moi je sais que je l'ai
apporté vous croyez que mon père avait
le temps de avait le temps de me laver
quand j'étais tout petite j'avais que 18
mois quand j'ai perdu ma mère qu'est-ce
que vous faisiez Maria quand il pleuvait
comme aujourd'hui et ben je me mettais
derrière le buisson et puis je
m'accroupissais et j'attendais que ça
passe aussi moi et je rentrais à la
maison quand j'étais trempe et quand il
y avait de la grê vous aviez pas peur ah
ben non mais on ne laissait pas mouiller
les brebis autre fois voyez-vous quand
il pleuvait aujourd'hui elles sont
dehors nuit et jour mais moi quand
j'étais petite la première goutte d'eau
il fallait les rentrer on ne laiss sait
pas mouiller les brebis alors ça m'
arrivé à les sortir comme des jours
comme aujourd'hui suppose il fallait les
sortir des fois deux trois fois dans la
journée comment c'était la maison vous
vous en souvenez oh vous savez la
maison on a fait plusieurs maisons alors
c'était comme tout le monde c'était la
terre la maison
il y avait de la terre puis il y avait
une cheminée puis il y avait souvent le
lit du père et de la mère dedans et
toutes les enfants couchai dans la même
chambre le soir et ben le soir on allait
au lit mais on couchait deux trois dans
le même lit il y en avait deux à la tête
puis deux au pied
souvent et la maison que je suis née je
ne vois pas de chambre je ne vois qu'une
seule pièce comment ça se passé la
lessive en famille
ça me demandait ça c'était on allit à la
pêcherie dans un ruisseau on l'avait à
l'eau froide en ce moment-là et on
faisait la lessive deux fois trois fois
par an c'est
tout la lessive de drap mais on prenait
des femmes vous voyez les femmes se
groupai trois quatre femmes qui ell se
mettaient ensemble pour laver la live
mais pas moi en fin du temps de mon père
mais moi je n'ai pas fait
ça
ah ah aussi pire pas oh
non
pas n pas
fr alors comment
piant
nous
ou le P noir vous saviez ce que c'était
ben certainement qu'on Mang du pain noir
et puis du pain qui était fait de 15
jours qui était moisi dites-moi Maria le
pain noir pour vous c'était
quoi vous savez le noir pour moi c'était
pas ridicule j'étais née en mangeant du
pain comme ça qu'on avait fait du pain
de sègle mais vu l'époque que je me
trouvais né en 1910 moi la guerre de 14
en 20 en 18 là les gens sont prpérés on
a commencé à manger du pain blanc alors
moi je n'avais que 10 ans donc je n'ai
pas bien connu cette grande misère moi
c'était du pain qui était fait avec de
la farine de
sgle avec de la farine de sgle parce que
on avait pas le terrain pour pousser
sans doute le le blé le blé demandait
davantage d'engré lui il demandait
davantage de soin que le
sgle alors comme on était pauvre on se
met beaucoup de sgle et on faisait notre
pain de
ça
mais il arrivait à ce pain de mal
vieillir non ah ben on le mangeait de 15
jours et quand il était moisi on le
jetait pas il fallait bien le
manger je m'en rappelle bien quand
j'étais enfant que ce pain était
tellement mauvais qu'il était moisi et
certainement on le crachait alors que
mon père disait tu n'as que mettre le la
bouchée mauvaise devant et prendre une
bonne
derrière et quand on mangeait les
châignes blanchies c'était souvent qu'il
ne voulait pas qu'on jette la mauvaise
il disait allez tu n'as que mangé la
mauvaise la première et puis la bonne
derrière et on le faisait mais le bon
pain de boulanger maintenant est bien
meilleur
il aurait pas fallu me faire manger de
bon pain et me remettre au pain
noir mais de fromage moi jamais je
n'avais mangé ni de beurre j'avais 20
ans quand j'ai mangé du beurre
moion même V trop oh là
là non
[Musique]
non vous n'avez pas de ride je n'ai pas
de ride non et parce que je me suis
levée de bonheur le 1er
mai
c'est-à-dire si bien jeer des
rides qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
pas en avoir et ben vous savez bien
qu'il faut se lever le 1er mai la
première quinzaine de mai avant le
soleil levé et aller se laver avec la
rosée du pré et Maria l'a fait moi je
l'ai fait une fois
oui et ça a marché oh je ne sais pas si
ça marché parce que ça m'a pas empêché
de vieillir et d'avoir des cheveux
blancs je n'allais pas au
bal j allé le temps que j'étais chez mon
père toute gosse à 11 ans 12 ans il me
laissait bien peu courir mais après ça a
été
fini chez les autres je n'ai plus été au
bal parce que je ne suis pas restée très
vieille avec mon
père je me suis enallé toute jeune il
vous a
placé je me suis bien placé tout seule
j'ai pas eu besoin de
Lui vous en avz envie de partir ah oui
par que je travaillais tellement et ben
j'étais tellement écuré du travail et
puis je voyais mes frères qui étaient
partis et moi je j'étais là qui est levé
les demi frères alors je suis
partie je suis partie comme ça mais
parti à la ville ou parti ah non j'ai
jamais voulu aller à à la campagne je
suis été en ville et jusqu'au jour que
je me suis mariée quand je me suis
mariée j'étais chez Monsieur Dupont à
bon les mines vous étiez toute jeune
quand vous êtes marié j'avais 19 ans
alors voyez-vous je me suis mariée pas
très vieille et puis après je suis été
avec mon mari et puis son père et sa
mère je suis rentrée Bru et puis après
on a pris mon mari après ses parents
étaient âgés alors il a été dans les
usines il a été dans l'élctricité
voyez-vous alors moi j'ai levé mes
enfants je ne travaillais plus la terre
est-ce que vous aurez envie de revenir
là où vous êtes né oui je serais
contente de revoir la maison mais enfin
je n'y suis jamais revenu j'ai habité
pas loin et je ne suis jamais revenu
voir ce village et je n'y connais plus
personne et vous avez pas envie d'y
aller non non ça me dit rien
maintenant il y a trop de souvenirs vous
savez les souvenirs
les embêtements quand on est gosse on
les met de côté on n pas de regret on on
ne regrette pas là on regrette lorsque
si parard vous êtes marié ou ben avant
de vous marier si vous faites une gaffe
vous regrettez là si j'avais su j'aurais
pas fait ça si j'avais su j'aurais opéré
comme ça ça aurait mieux marché quelque
chose comme ça mais l'enfance vous savez
ça vient et ça passe ça
personne m'a fait beaucoup de mal alors
les petites misères que j'ai eu savez
moi je m'en fous je je tiens pas rancune
de
[Musique]
ça